best to downplay an over 300 percent
surge in hate crimes against asian
americans
by blaming trump
we've seen this rise unfortunately
because of hate-filled rhetoric and
language around the
the origins of the pandemic um and that
is something that asian americans across
the country have been feeling
i want to teleport myself to the
briefing okay tomorrow and say jen could
you point to any evidence that anybody
was motivated by
the covid19 lab leak theory
to smash some asian woman in the head
with a baseball bat it's like a hate
crime you actually have to be able to
add some circumstantial evidence to
point that it's based upon hate you know
in this case based upon donald trump
saying it's the coronavirus from china
that's only if you see it as a real
problem they just see it as a political
problem so they just use the typical
platitudes they always use they make it
up she's a huge problem for saying that
there are women being murdered i i just
can't imagine homeless men sitting
around scrolling on their iphones going
like oh
did you see what trump said about the
lab league let's go beat up an asian
woman i mean how insulting to the family
of that dead woman that you have a
political leader who represents a party
who goes up there i mean if there were
asian lives matter right now you would
be out in front of the white house
unfortunately you're not there yet you
need to these guys need to mobilize
because no one is helping the asians
right now at least in new york city
they're putting more homeless shelters
in chinatown that's only going to raise
the risk for violence no one cares
because you know what they're not
politically viable to the democrats they
don't the democrats don't care yeah you
haven't heard a lot of outrage about
that and you were just mentioning these
homeless shelters that are going into
chinatown and you know listen if if you
see someone you're a deranged maniac and
you see a woman who's walking around by
herself you're probably going to take a
shot if you're that crazy well yes and i
do stick around also for the next block
because we're going to talk about the
increasing voting power of asian
americans which is starting to happen
in certain places we'll see that in
california especially with the school
board but in this case there's a
concerned citizens east of east broadway
and they said that i asked what is the
one thing that you the city could do
right now to help your community and he
said well not put an additional four
homeless shelters in our neighborhood
only one of those shelters would be for
families the rest were single males
and if you we didn't even mention the
other crime it's of course there was a
woman shoved in from the subway there
was the woman that was hit by the
baseball bat what about the woman who
was tracked into her apartment and
stabbed multiple times and then the
guy's found hiding under her bed
that guy is definitely not doing this
because of trump why don't they attack
the criminal
instead of the person in the white house
the criminals are victims because their
modus operandi is to protect the
criminal to release the criminal the
criminal is the victim but here's the
connection between all of those excuses
we want cities safe and democrats are
coming up with any excuse they can pull
out of the air whether it's mayor eric
adams whether it's aoc or whether it's
jens hockey and i got to tell you
something remember yesterday we talked
about aoc saying the child tax credit is
gone so everybody's stealing and
committing crimes i call my accountant
now i'm not involved i don't have a
child tax credit uh the bottom line is
the child tax credit is not gone it's
been increased from uh to 3 000 from
2000 to 3 600 for children under 5. it's
called the advanced child tax credit and
he sent it to me today he said i'll give
you the exact section okay so that's a
lie number one number two when eric
adams says you know what the the this
press conference room is you know it's
not diverse enough no eric you're
smarter than that talk about the crime
and jenn sake you proved to me just as
you said jesse that there is a nexus
between uh donald trump and these people
like are they yelling i hate you because
of the coronavirus or that's because i
got coven or that's cause my
mother-in-law that's a bunch of hogwash
i wish it was as simple as
shelters in chinatown
this is a lot deeper it's a lot more
disturbing this this points to something
very sick in society this is racism it's
racism directed against asians most of
the perpetrators if not all in recent
cases are
are black men
there's something awful going on here
that we can't get our arms around we
can't we can't face it i think i'm the
only commentator on tv that actually
identifies who the perpetrators are
racially speaking because there's this
uh this dancing around the issue this is
a sickness this is a cancer we have to
deal with it eric adams has to deal with
it and i i like him i support him i
think he's doing a as good a job as he
possibly can in the last month that he's
been in office this one month he's been
in office this is a tough city but this
particular problem and how you you
i have uh a dear friend of our family
who goes around she was great big
glasses so you can see that she's asian
puts a hood on and her mom or elderly
mom it is pathetic it is sick that this
is happening but we have to confront it
for what it is
this is racism so why won't mayor adams
confront it well i i think that this
would just what i said is so incendiary
can you imagine eric adams saying what i
just said even i imagine him fighting
for victims is what i imagine well i i
think that he has to understand that
this problem this is a deep deep problem
it has to be confronted you need al
sharpton on this you need every one of
these civil rights leaders
so asian people are so
far gone mentally ill that this isn't
about tweeting out and asian hate it's
about just locking them up exactly you
need it i don't think i don't think at
this point these people have been locked
up let go lock up like this guy at 44 44
times uh oh no that was stabbed a dozen
times to 40. i wonder if he's ever been
asked
during a lucid moment you know when
they're on their meds or whatever why
did you do it why this asian woman why
why did you do this it should be in the
police report
someone should ask me because
you saw the police report but and he
mentioned he mentioned the china virus
if it's in the police report and it's on
trump
but it's not yeah and i think the five
should take a field trip to the briefing
room and we'll all ask jen saki somebody
okay oh that'll be starting
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else